herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute zusammen mit der wand und ihr seid
auch ihr wisst ihr warum ich schon so
richtig verrückt drauf bin warum genau
wo wir spielen heute das habe ich schon
einmal gemacht ein trinkspiel wo es
einfach nur darum geht möglichst ich
gerade sollten sie möglichst viel
fruchtsaft mit sprudel zu sich zu nehmen
denn wir haben einen alkoholfreien sekt
geholt ok und die öffnet die bar
ich sage es mal so ich es geht auf
meinen nacken hit machen wir die barmer
einfach auf wir haben hier will man da
noch dranhängen oder da kann man so
richtig als auch das sieht so voll die
sparflamme ist wenn wir einen 2009 10
mehr jahrgang und ja wir spielen heute
wie gesagt ein trinkspiel und zwar dass
dir das im fc sturm und gran
irgendwelche einwände
ach stimmt so nicht warum es losgeht
über alle die älter als 25 sind trinken
er würde mir eine stimme hast du ja ihr
seid ihr
ich bin 20 echt dass der junge als ob du
es 20 bis erich daher dachte er 13 jahre
alt wird das irgendwie so dass in oder
unter der besucher das alter sagt würden
sich bezwang auf der bahn
ich bin 22 aber ich wollte noch kurz
sagen schnell vom maxim aus dem
propeller hier oben drauf
die originalen kanäle oder ok viel
schminke
alle die ein iphone haben trinken vier
stücke wie abgeschrieben
denn letztlich leer alter aber wir haben
die aber unterschiedlich stark
gesellschaft ist der alkohol ideen um
keinen kater zu bekommen sagt
nacheinander eure ideen die personen die
keine nicht hinten wert oder eigentlich
wiederholt rink fünf stücken beginn nur
freunde mit katzenallergie haben ich bin
da nicht einfach keinen kaufen zu
bekommen
dazu kommt kein karte wenn du kein kauft
ja und nein dass wir die anderen schenkt
man muss es komplett verhindert dass der
spieler der die größte münzen es ist
super aber bereits wieder jemand dem der
sieben stücke bringen oder zu behalten
und selbst 72 euro münze und sie haben
ein problem da vorne jungs jetzt rita
gewiss nicht zum spaß werden münster ich
habe jemand keine und mitte jemals eine
münze die last die gastgeberinnen mit
solcher to use okay ihr trinkt jeweils
drei ich gebe mir selbst ein sprechen
wir auch besoffen werden biete jedem
spieler eine schluckauf bei einem glas
sind die anderen net trinken sie
ansonsten trinkst du ihrem klub jeweils
selbst diplomierter beantwortet größten
schalker
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sturm noch einen schluck anbieter
zugelassen
sturm zehn ateliers spiel gran risa
großmutter gedacht ab jetzt nicht mehr
deine zähne zeigen
das ist gefragt wenn es dann einmal in
einem anderen land selber auto gefahren
wird verteilt trinken bis die chance
aber eben auch nicht muss zu trinken
komm komm mal her dass wir nichts gehört
10 und sie sind also sich die ihre seite
[Gelächter]
tdf von party ganz schlecht ging
in zwei stücke wenn sie beeren mit ihr
recht schlicht und ich habe beim
vornamen anspricht gemacht dass sie
mussten
das ist ja auch gewünscht dass noch drin
jeder gehört wohin sie erklärten es ist
der apfelsaft drin da also häufiger
stücke vorteil wieder umkehrt ich habe
drei bischöfe machen
du bist zwar okay und ich wollte es mir
helfen
na ja richtig geil oder zugriffe den
nacken kopf vor war stets mit euch hier
an den kletter oder so geht und wir
haben wenn sie ein keyboard überbelastet
und es kribbelt wenn du da bist du auch
tust ist zu hart können wenn die balance
zu halten koste dann machst du mit dem
java und daher auch meine hunde roma an
spring fürs budget wenn du denkst morgen
aspirin nehmen zu müssen
das ist eine frage die personen die
zuerst antwortet verteilt zweifel
der nächste schritt ist ein
statistischer effekt junge hilfreich
alters geht um haben wir den computer ja
deswegen mit verrückt was du siehst ja
geil kann wenn du dich von einer
arbeitslos melden mussten brink zwei
stücke ansonsten verteilt sie absurd
wunde musste noch nie
der von der pole ist er teil aber auch
max halt nicht
[Gelächter]
aha also die mehr als zwei sportarten
also die mit alle die wehrpflicht hätte
also die welt zwei sport in einem verein
gespielt haben trinken zwei stücke ich
konnte
was also dass wir in 10 21 verletzten
die arbeiter den warten noch eine
extreme challenge ab und dann war's das
hat irgendwie die themen spiel und zwei
schlüssel für den verlierer ideale
lebens mittel gegen durchfall beginnt
okay ich sag essen ohne ballaststoffe
das ist zu altern ist desto dicker
erstmal ohne beider stoffe ist kein
niveau kann das lebensmittel weil essen
keine lebensmittel sind richtig coole
tabletten enthalten sind oder lebens mit
den alten kulturen
[Musik]
wasser man muss viel trinken nein nein
nein das papier das an und baten sie die
durchfahrt hätte ich kann mir die person
gesagt eigentlich dauerhaft prüfen das
kunstherz lassen wasser gegen durchfall
vor ihren weil du als vorbild und jetzt
es dann gegen tot
[Musik]
nein süßigkeiten süßigkeiten keine
ballaststoffen das hilfsgeld reihe wie
gesehen das schöne krone schieben oder
salz stand ja cola bananensaft kay one
man band wahrscheinlich auf dem sektor
der ccc cc c
[Musik]
so leute dass man vom heutigen video ich
hoffe mal sehr
es hat euch gefallen falls ihr euch
jetzt geht's so sieht diesen kanal zu
abonnieren oder crea bonn ihren war
denkt das nochmal überdenken
am besten beides noch ich mache mich
immer solche videos
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal